how are you doing i know you took a
little spill i just wanted to have a fun
time
and it's these little things that i've
i've been forced to
focus on and find there's these little
things that make me happy just
momentarily
and even if they're dangerous
read girl you are giving us the
full-fledged glam darling
i know i got i had to put it all
together tonight i have not
been in this much glam
the entire quarantine of course i've
been just
sitting in robes with no makeup and
whatever my hair does that day but
hey okay thank you for you you know what
i'm saying
hey now thank you for getting cute for
me today because i don't know if you
know what today is
but today marks a year ago that we
reconnected
at the barclays center for the big fenty
fashion show last year
and both wow friend friend diversary
[Laughter]
is it not crazy to think that that was
just a year ago
that we could actually be
face to face i know and we were just
like throwing jabs back and forth
and having fun with each other in the
flesh now we'll have to
surprise the zoom but girl let's talk
about
this production because last year it was
off the chain
this year what can we get what can we
expect this year what are the logistics
going into it
well it's definitely still going to be
off the chain you know you wouldn't see
it otherwise
but i i know that it's definitely a lot
more challenging logistically there are
a lot of
moving parts a lot of moving people and
you you know everyone's health obviously
comes
first so it's trying to stay on top of
that and make sure that everyone's good
on top of a production
that relies on everyone's health it's
presented its challenges
but we love a challenge and we were just
grateful that amazon prime was up for
the challenge with us
yeah so where are you going to be
shooting it this year you're taping it
obviously
how many models are going to be involved
men women what's cooking
definitely men women
non-binary there's there's going to be
an array
of personalities and i'm excited to
present this show with with
new product that we've actually been
designing since
our last show while we were making the
last show we were actually creating
this collection so it's fantastic to see
it
finally come to fruition um i'm
particularly excited about um
our male representation from christian
combs
we're doing a collaboration with him
which is really special to us
he's the latest collaborator for the
brand and and he's
uh he's worn randomly a customized
boxer brief last year which had the
ladies going a little bit crazy
you know what come over to savage and
make them yeah
i'm i wear them all the time so i'm
excited to have to see
how people interpret that new franchise
in our in our brand
and of course last time that we spoke
you told me that you feel like you have
been busier than ever
even in the midst of a pandemic so
clearly that is the case
how do you continue to keep yourself
inspired and motivated during
times like these hmm
you know i start to dial back a lot
because there's a lot happening always
and when i get
into those little crevices of these huge
moments
i i just try to think about
what i really love to do like what truly
makes me happy and
it's really the littlest things it could
be
cooking it could be walking it could be
biking girl you've been [ __ ]
scooting but i've heard about that
little it's all of these little tiny
things that you just do for fun that
in the moment they just make you feel
great
yeah i don't have a license so i can't
really drive but driving is also one of
those things that are therapeutic
well honey no yeah i'm gonna back up a
little bit because you mentioned
scooting and being on a like being on an
electric scooter how are you doing
i know you took a little spill i'm doing
like i'm doing tremendously
better i mean when i saw those pictures
of you come out with the bruises i was
like
free girl you and simon cowell need to
be in timeout
i know thank god it wasn't as bad as his
honestly i'm really grateful that it
wasn't as
as intense but you know back
to what you were saying i just wanted to
have a fun time
and it's these little things that i've
i've been forced to
focus on and find these little things
that make me happy just
momentarily and even if they're
dangerous
ray girl you gotta be careful
i know trust me i'll i'll go slower next
time okay
yeah might be having to put that scooter
away for the time being and
you know you're talking about what you
know what's scary what's that
i'm probably not i'm probably not going
to put the scooter away that's what
nana you need to reel it in mama you got
a lot of business i would definitely not
do it before a savage
production okay yes
but after i'll be back
you've got all sorts of details going
into savage xfenty for your upcoming
fall collection i hear even some like
embroidery
of your own doodles into the mix of some
of the designs is that correct yeah
yeah it was just it was a random little
fun doodle night because it was supposed
to be personal it was supposed to be
a play on a diary and i i figured just
let's
doodle and design what the diary would
look like because in my diary
it's full of empty pages we even have
these little merch
merch diaries that we gave as gifts that
the doodles are
outside of and the pages are empty for
you to journal whatever you want to
journal in them i've been coloring all
of them but
we incorporated that into the embroidery
in the lace
and it's like a fun little
uh sub collection within the entire
show so good girl you are always working
on something and that is something that
you told me
in late july when i last spoke with you
you said that
you know you're always constantly
working on music and something that
we've always gone back and forth on and
everything but how are times in this
world
today how are they impacting your music
and what you're working on whether or
not you want to put it out right now
yeah um it impacts everything it impacts
the timing
for a lot impacts touring it impacts
uh how feasible it is to
travel or have people that you want to
work with travel to you
it forces you to figure it out
and and i'm i'm that type of girl i i
just want to figure out a solution i
don't want to stay stuck on on the
problem i want to like okay so what do
we do about it
yeah and with covet every day
has been so what do you do about it
because there's always a challenge
every day something different every
single day
and so the what do you do about it
aspect has come into
uh full play during this quarantine and
and it's it's helped a lot and it's
forced me to figure things out
and get creative and clever about it
we've been spoiled we've really been
spoiled and this is a humbling
experience
you